i'm curious for you guys with everything
that you each have on your plates i
would imagine you put a lot of thought
into what you want to devote time to
since putting time toward one thing
means taking it from another thing
so why was this the perfect project for
you guys
uh it was a great opportunity to work
together on a project we would
we wanted to do that for a while and uh
when the concept of
about last night which is based on a old
game show called title tales and putting
our our new age spin on it um
it was a great
way to meet other couples
spend time with couples we already knew
um
show the power relationships and all
different you know
forms of it and and and bring the fun
and and the humor uh to it but also
the the vulnerability and like you said
the scandalous nature that we are
questions and themes that we all kind of
can relate to so
uh it was a perfect kind of recipe with
everything each of you guys have very
successful careers in other areas than
hosting a reality show and being
successful in other areas doesn't mean
you'll be a good host so
what do you think it is that is the key
to being a good host
i think listening is very important
um but just we worked really hard on
creating a safe space for everybody that
came through
and not taking ourselves too seriously i
think really helped make everybody
comfortable
so i think that was the key for us
yeah the vibe on the show was definitely
one of the best things about it i mean
it just felt like i would just love to
come hang out there at any time
yeah kind of what you see is what you
get that's really how it felt on set
um nothing to do with the editing
i love the effortless diversity of the
show you have couples with athletes
actors comedians you have people from a
variety of backgrounds different races
people who are gay and straight
was that something that you put much
thought into was it important to you to
create that type of everyone is welcome
environment absolutely that was like our
non-starter that was our non-negotiable
we wanted to make sure that we had all
different versions of love on this show
um and we thought that it'd be a great
representation of how everybody can get
together and just have a good time
stefan i have to ask whose idea was it
to have your sister and brother-in-law
on the show and how quickly did you
regret having that idea
about question two of their uh of their
episodes when i realized they could go
south pretty quick
that i've been prepared mentally for the
answers that i was gonna hear
um but it was it was a no-brainer to
have him on the show that first just
because you want to be able to uh
um you know experience what a game show
is like and the questions we're gonna
ask you know with some family
but yeah i immediately regretted it for
sure
it was fine
was there like some family therapy
involved after you're like we need to
never mention this again
yeah yeah pretty much i had to think
about watching the uh the screener of
that episode uh yeah
[Laughter]
well with all of the ups and downs that
you guys have seen each other go through
and come out of the other side of
what impresses each of you about the
others stephen what impresses you about
aisha and aisha what impresses you about
stefan
i think just her overall uh her
creativity and her passion for sharing
her gifts with the world like
um you know she built it pretty much out
of nothing with an idea of just sharing
recipes out of her own kitchen
um with her own one single camera she
had and now building it was
uh i call it an empire she hates that
word but um
of
you know ways that she can bring
families together
um you know to make sure that food is
the ultimate you know
uh gathering place for family to spend
time together and to connect
and she found a lot of different ways to
share that with the world and um she
brings a
positivity to it all as well that is
very relatable and very
uh relevant in these times that we're
living in so
that's the biggest thing and
now i hear a lot of people when i'm on
the road or i'm
uh at arenas and all that like calling
out my name we're like hey we we
we love you but we love your wife even
more
for for me it's watching him balance it
all they say like you can't they say
balance doesn't exist but i'm i'm
closest to him on a daily basis and i
literally watch him balance it all and
never complain a day in his life and
some days that makes me jealous because
i'm like how how how i'm watching
everything that you're doing and i don't
understand how you're managing it all
with such grace and class and ease
and so i think that's the thing that i
admire the most about you with with
everything that you do is your work
ethic your passion and your ability to
just balance i appreciate it we need to
cut that these those two answers and i
need to have those on repeat
well for for all the people that look up
to you guys and who are inspired by your
success and everything you've achieved
do you ever get nervous do you get
nervous at the start of every endeavor
do you get nervous before every game did
you get nervous before doing this show
and how do you
channel that to use it to your advantage
yeah i was uh i've talked to a lot of
athletes and
uh
just for advice and i asked that
specific question a lot of people and i
mean the the answer you usually get is
if you're not nervous that means it
doesn't matter to you and if you ever
um are doing anything where you don't
get that those butterflies in your
stomach or
the anxiousness to to you know be great
at what you're doing you're probably
doing the wrong thing so
uh with
my career her career this show
it's all important it all matters and
and you want to be successful at what
you do and what you put your your mind
to and your efforts to so
um i think that's a good
it's a good uh experi experience to go
through um but you got to kind of learn
how to
to manage that you know yourself and you
know with the reps and
um
i think we figured that out do you feel
the same way i mean i do get nervous too
is it something you have to overcome oh
i always have to get like talked down
like i i i stay nervous i'm always like
so extremely
just petrified
anytime i'm doing anything um so it
takes a lot of uh talking through to get
me going but once i get into it i'm
usually okay and i think that the nerves
actually help me push through
once you had this show and you needed to
line up these couples to appear did you
have like an immediate list of people
you knew you had to get on the show was
there anyone you were most excited to
hear from
we didn't have an immediate list we just
knew we wanted um our
our list and our cast to be super
diverse
um for for this season and for the
foreseeable future of the show
um that was what was most important to
us so
um but looking forward uh in the future
if we are so lucky to have a season two
uh i think barack and michelle are on
top of listen
eight times in a row yeah
that definitely feels like it would be
quite a fun episode yeah for sure what
are the biggest challenges in hosting
something like this was it ever hard to
stay on track and stay focused on the
show instead of just wanting to have fun
and hang out with everybody yes it was
so hard to stay
on track and not get off on a tangent
because i mean a lot of these couples
that came on are just so freaking funny
like we would have to cut and hold for
laughs because even the crew would just
fall apart everybody was just
hysterical so i think like controlling
the humor and the laughter a little bit
was probably the hardest part absolutely
yeah i love how even though you feel
like you know some of these people so
well or even just how much the viewers
will think they know you guys you really
learn something about everybody from
watching these episodes
yeah yeah
it's part of the uh just the the at-home
vibe that we wanted to create with even
just the set and the questions and even
our approach to it it's like we're in
our
uh you know in a basement on the couches
just talking um you know
passing the time with good good
conversation good humor and uh we tried
to bring up with every episode and the
couples they they felt right at home and
and uh
they shared so you get some good uh with
some good answers from them
well thank you guys for talking to me
about it and please make more of the
show i enjoyed it tremendously
thank you so much
thanks a lot